مشحونا بخيانه اقرب حلفاء مايك بنس الذي
صرح بتطلع اعضاء الحزب لقياده جديده
ونكراني جميل ديسانس الذي ما كان ليصبح
حاكما لولا دعمه كما يقول
بيبي
[تصفيق]
كاليفورنيا وان كانت ترامب خسر رهان
الموجه الحمراء في انتخابات 2022 النصفيه
لكن الرهانات السياسيه تتغير وفقا لمعطيات
جديده معطيات اليوم تقول وفقا للاستطلاع
لام بي سي اجرته ام بي سي نيوز فان قضيتي
الوثائق السريه التي عثر عليها في منتجع
ترامب وتلك التي ظلت في مركز بايدن البحري
ومنزله لسنوات والتي يجرى البحث عن المزيد
منها تعد من ابرز القضايا اللتان تشغلان
الراي العام الامريكي بشكل متساوي مع قضيه
اكتشاف وثائق سريه لدى مايك بنز نائب
ترامب حصل الرئيس السابق على هديه مفاجئه
تجعله اكثر عزما على العوده الحادثتان
جعلتاه يتشارك الاتهامات بسوء التصرف
بمستندات تخص الامن القومي مع مسؤولا
جمهوريا واخر ديمقراطي
هو نفس السؤال
الامريكيون اليوم عليه فكيف يمكن لرئيس
الولايات المتحده ان ينسى وثائق سريه بقيت
لسنوات في غرفه المجاوره لمراه بمنزله
منصاته الديمقراطيين الاعلاميه حاولت
الاجابه بايضا لم ينتهك القوانين لانه لم
يعلم بوجودها والمحاموها بادروا فورا
بالابلاغ عنها رغم انهم ابقوا الاكتشاف
الثاني سرا حتى سربت قناه سي بي اس القصه
والروايه ان دفعه المستندات الاولى دفعه
المستندات الاولى وجدت داخل خزانه مقفله
وهي تعزز موقف الرئيس وحرصه بان حصنه
الوثائق التي لم يعلن عن مستوى سريتها بعد
ظلت بمكان امن لكن في نفس الوقت ذات
المنصات تصنف حادثه ترامب بالجريمه وتبرر
بان مقاومته والمحاصره محاصره قوات الاف
بي اي لمقر وجودها وانتشار صوره تؤكد
السريه المواد وعددها كبير تعرضه للمحاسبه
بموجب قانون التجسس الامريكي في حين ان
المنصات المناصره للترامب تقول ان للرئيس
السابق الحق باخذ المستندات وهو لم يخرق
القانون لانه نزع السريه عنها شفهيا قبل
تركيب منصبه المفارقه ان ترامبوا بايدن
وحتى اوباما فرضوا عقوبات جنائيه قاسيه
على المسربين للوثائق والمبلغين في عهدهم
بصوره اكبر من غيرهم والمفارقه الاكبر ان
بايدن الذي امضى عقودا كعدوا في مجلس
الشيوخ يعزز قوانين تحاكم الكشف غير
السليم عن المعلومات السريه حاكمت الاداره
التي كان جزءا منها اكبر عددا من
المخالفين بموجب قانون التجسس اكثر من
جميع الادارات الامريكيه في التاريخ
مجتمعه
[موسيقى]